It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值传粉盛季，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢异常忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这绝对是一个不会常有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. NASA has said that it's working towards sending humans to Mars sometime in the 2030s. A round-trip mission to Mars, which is 140 million miles from Earth, would take at least three years. For the astronauts, that would mean three years of confinement in a small space and limited or delayed communications with those back on Earth. As engineers consider the technical challenges involved in long-term space exploration, psychologists and other behavioral science. scientists are thinking about the human challenges. Today we're going to talk to a NASA psychologist about what those challenges are and how scientists are working to address them. We'll discuss the skills and supports that astronauts will need to stay mentally and physically healthy on such a long trip.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭受数据流量降速。美国国家航空航天局 (NASA) 表示，该机构正致力于在 2030 年代某个时候将人类送上火星。火星距离地球 1.4 亿英里，一次火星往返任务将至少耗时三年。对于宇航员来说，这意味着三年时间将被禁锢在一个狭小的空间里，并且与地球上的亲友通讯受限或存在延迟。正当工程师们思考长期太空探索中所涉及的技术挑战时，心理学家和其他行为科学科学家正在思考人类面临的挑战。今天，我们将与一位 NASA 心理学家交流，探讨这些挑战是什么以及科学家们正如何着手解决这些挑战。我们将讨论宇航员在如此漫长的旅程中保持身心健康所需的技能和支持。
How does NASA determine who has the right stuff for such a trip? How will they avoid the potential pitfalls of isolation and confinement? What skills will they need to work effectively as a team? and how to personality and other behavioral traits factor into astronaut selection. What do we know from prior space missions? And how can researchers study and prepare astronauts for long-term space travel while they're here on Earth? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
NASA 如何确定谁具备执行此类任务的合适素质？他们将如何避免孤立和禁锢带来的潜在陷阱？他们需要哪些技能才能作为一个团队高效协作？人格以及其他行为特征在宇航员选拔中是如何起作用的？从以往的太空任务中我们了解到了什么？研究人员又该如何在地球上研究并帮助宇航员为长期的太空旅行做好准备？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Suzanne Bell, an industrial, organizational psychologist who leads the behavioral health and performance lab at NASA Johnson Space Center in Houston. There, she and her colleagues study the human aspects of space exploration, including the skills and supports that astronauts will need on future long-term missions. Dr. Bell has a background studying teamwork and team effectiveness. Before joining NASA full-time in 2021, she was a psychology professor at DePaul University. Dr. Bell, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me, Sam.
我是金·米尔斯 (Kim Mills)。我今天的嘉宾是苏珊·贝尔 (Suzanne Bell) 博士，她是一位工业与组织心理学家，领导着位于休斯敦的 NASA 约翰逊航天中心的行为健康与绩效实验室。在那里，她和同事们研究太空探索中的人类因素，包括宇航员在未来长期任务中所需的技能和支持。贝尔博士拥有研究团队合作和团队效能的背景。在 2021 年全职加入 NASA 之前，她是德保罗大学的心理学教授。贝尔博士，非常感谢您今天做客我们的节目。谢谢邀请我来，萨姆。
Can you start by giving listeners an overview of what you and your colleagues work on at NASA's Behavioral Health and Performance Lab? What are the big questions you're trying to answer? Oh, wow. Well, you summarize the kind of challenges of future spaceflight. And what our lab is really charged with is looking to the future. So when we go to Artemis missions, which will be our missions returning to the moon, when we go on to Mars, what are the challenges, what are the risk? what are the risks of spaceflight and how do those affect behavioral health performance and a team functioning, team performance. And then once we understand those risks and how do they evolve,
您可以先向听众简要介绍一下您和同事们在 NASA 的行为健康与绩效实验室从事哪些工作吗？你们试图回答的重大问题是什么？哦，哇。嗯，你总结了未来太空飞行面临的各种挑战。而我们实验室真正肩负的职责是放眼未来。因此，当我们执行阿尔忒密斯任务（即重返月球的任务）时，当我们进军火星时，面临的挑战是什么，风险是什么？太空飞行的风险是什么，它们又将如何影响行为健康、绩效以及团队协作和团队表现？接着，一旦我们理解了这些风险及其演变过程，
how do we develop interventions, countermeasures, support, how to select people, whatever we can do to help astronauts survive and thrive in that incredibly demanding circumstance? What are the biggest challenges that astronauts will face on a long-term mission like a trip to Mars that they haven't faced on shorter trips into space? So the way the International Space Station is right now, which is where we go into space, we call it low Earth orbit. It's fairly near Earth. You can get there relatively quickly.
我们该如何开发干预措施、应对策略、支持方案、如何选拔人员，以及我们能做些什么来帮助宇航员在那种极其苛刻的环境中生存并茁壮成长？与以往较短时间的太空飞行相比，宇航员在诸如火星之旅这样的长期任务中将面临哪些他们从未经历过的最大挑战？以国际空间站目前的现状来看，也就是我们进入太空的地方，我们称之为近地轨道。它离地球相当近。你可以相对较快地到达那里。
It's still difficult, but you are somewhat protected from some of the radiation effects that you would have in deep space. you can come back within a couple days if really necessary for a medical emergency. And even one other thing I'll point out is when crew do complicated things like Spacewalk, they have real-time support from Mission Control. If you watch a Spacewalk on NASA TV, you can hear the back and forth and the back-and-forth. Mission Control is providing expertise. Astronauts are executing really complicated feats.
这仍然很困难，但你在一定程度上免受了深空辐射效应的影响。如果出于医疗紧急情况确实有必要，你可以在几天内返回。我还要指出另一件事，当机组人员执行复杂的任务（如太空行走）时，他们可以从任务控制中心获得实时支持。如果你在 NASA 电视台观看太空行走，你可以听到双方的实时对话。任务控制中心提供专业知识。宇航员则在执行非常复杂的壮举。
And this is in real time. as we move to our moon missions, things start to get more complicated. Now we're talking about a vehicle that's instead of the size of the International Space Station, which is about a five-bedroom house size equivalent. Now we're talking about a really small space, tiny space, in fact. Right now our missions are planned to use Orion as one of the ways that we get at least to the moon and to the orbit of the moon. And so that is a tiny space. You're now having to live with people, four people in a really small space, as I mentioned,
这是实时的。随着我们转向登月任务，事情开始变得更加复杂。现在我们讨论的飞行器，不再是国际空间站那样大约相当于五居室房屋大小的规模。现在我们谈论的是一个非常小的空间，事实上是极小的空间。目前，我们的任务计划将猎户座飞船作为至少到达月球和月球轨道的方式之一。因此，那是一个极小的空间。正如我所提到的，你现在必须和几个人——四个人——挤在一个非常小的空间里生活，
there starts to be communication delays. So when we do spacewalks down to Earth, the person who is helping the spacewalk will have real-time communication with the person on spacewalk, but we'll start to have five to 10-second delays back to mission control. So imagine, you know, transferring information where some people you're talking to real-time, some is on a calm delay. Beyond that, they'll also be exposed to higher levels of radiation. When we go on to Mars, it becomes even more complicated. Now you're talking about a two and a half year mission in a very small space. And as we get to the Mars surface, when Mars is at its
通信延迟开始出现。因此，当我们进行太空行走的地面支持时，协助太空行走的人将与太空行走的人进行实时通信，但对于任务控制中心，我们将开始出现 5 到 10 秒的延迟。所以想象一下，你知道，传输信息时，有些人是实时对话，有些则存在通信延迟。除此之外，他们还将暴露在更高水平的辐射中。当我们前往火星时，情况会变得更加复杂。现在我们要讨论的是一个在极小空间里持续两年半的任务。当我们到达火星表面时，当火星处于其
greatest distance from Earth, a 22-minute communication delay each way. So imagine that right now, when we have problems on the international space station or challenging the spacewalks, that real-time communication, it'll take 22 minutes for Earth to even understand or know if the crew has successfully landed or if they're successfully doing an EVA. And if they need help, they'll have another 22 minutes to wait for that response. So at a minimum, we might be at 44-minute delays. So now you're asking a small team to live in a small space, live in isolation for a long period of time, be exposed to radiation in a much higher quantities. And on top of that, do what hundreds of people would normally do with a crew of four in whatever computer supports we can send. So it's really asking a lot of the astronauts and the crew that will someday go in and be the first ones to land on Mars.
距离地球最远的位置，单程通信延迟长达 22 分钟。所以想象一下，目前当国际空间站出现问题或太空行走面临挑战时，通过实时通信，地球甚至需要 22 分钟才能理解或知晓机组人员是否成功着陆，或者他们是否在成功执行舱外活动。如果他们需要帮助，他们还得再等 22 分钟才能得到回复。因此，最少我们可能会面临 44 分钟的延迟。现在，你要求一个小团队在一个狭小的空间里生活，在孤立状态下生活很长时间，并暴露在数量高得多的辐射中。最重要的是，在任何我们能发送的计算机支持下，仅凭四名机组人员去完成数百名正常情况下由大批人员完成的工作。因此，这对未来某天将成为第一批登陆火星的宇航员和机组人员提出了非常高的要求。
So how are the skill sets different for these long-term astronauts at your screening now? How are they different from the astronauts who just go to the International Space Station or do shorter trips? Yeah. So we look at different competencies that are needed for different mission scenarios. And some things that really increase in importance in longer-term missions, such we're expecting to Mars, would be this idea of someone to be able to be resilient and really be able to engage in self-care because if you can't take care of yourself in terms of nutrition, working out, keeping your body healthy, keeping your mind healthy, then you're not going to be a good team player, especially in extreme circumstances like that. Teamwork is extremely important. They'll have to
那么，你们现在筛选的这些长期宇航员的技能组合有什么不同？他们与仅仅去国际空间站或执行较短任务的宇航员有何不同？是的。因此，我们着眼于不同任务场景所需的各种能力。在更长期的任务中（例如我们预期的火星任务），重要性真正增加的一些因素包括：某人能够具备韧性并真正能够进行自我照顾，因为如果你在营养、锻炼、保持身体健康和心理健康方面无法照顾好自己，那么你将无法成为一个好的团队成员，尤其是在那种极端情况下。团队合作极其重要。他们将不得不
coordinate seamlessly on these complex tasks. But if you're not even healthy yourself first, you know, we really need all four people. So they need self-care to contribute. Other things that become critically important are these group living skills. So right now there's a lot of privacy in the International Space Station. Yes, it's, you know, living with people and similar to a house. But if you go to bed at night, you can have your own private chamber or, you know, there's a food that can be resupplied, and so there's the possibility to kind of get preference in what you want to eat. When we're talking about Mars, it's so resource restricted. And so really someone who's able to be flexible and still do things like eat, regardless of what's, you know, left to eat
在这些复杂任务上进行无缝协调。但是，如果你自己甚至都还没保持健康，你知道的，我们真的需要全部四个人。因此，他们需要自我照顾才能做出贡献。变得极其重要的其他因素还有这些群体生活技能。目前，国际空间站有很大的隐私空间。是的，这，你知道的，与人共同生活，类似于一栋房子。但如果你晚上去睡觉，你可以有自己的私人舱室，或者，你知道的，食物可以得到补给，因此可以对你想吃的东西有一定的偏好。当我们谈论火星时，资源是如此受限。因此，真正需要的是一个能够保持灵活性并且依然能够做诸如吃饭之类事情的人，而不管，你知道的，还剩下什么可吃的，
and, you know, be able to effectively navigate living together in a really small space and be able to maintain positive relations so they can execute that complicated teamwork and come back. So what does the testing look like to screen astronauts? I mean, this is not a simple thing. You can't just have people fill out a paper questionnaire and say, I'm resilient. I mean, how do you determine that they really are? It's a very competitive process to be an astronaut. A lot of people have dreamed to being an astronaut since they were little kids. You know, we all look up into the stars and dream maybe someday that'll be us. So in more recent astronaut selection cycles, we've had as many as 20,000 people apply to something like eight to 10 slots, right? And so as you're pointing out,
并且，你知道的，能够有效地适应在一个非常小的空间里共同生活，并能够维持积极的关系，以便他们能够执行那项复杂的团队合作并返回。那么，筛选宇航员的测试是什么样的？我的意思是，这并不是一件简单的事情。你不能只让人们填写一份纸质问卷然后说，我有韧性。我的意思是，你们如何确定他们真的具备这种素质？成为一名宇航员是一个竞争非常激烈的过程。许多人从小就梦想成为一名宇航员。你知道的，我们都仰望星空，梦想着或许有一天那会是我们。因此，在最近的宇航员选拔周期中，有多达 2,0000 人申请仅有的八到十个名额，对吧？正如你所指出的，
you know, it can't just be self-report bubbles and you kind of go on with your life and hope that they responded correctly because you'd have about 20, 20,000 people saying, you know, five out of five on resilience. And then you put them in a tin can and it doesn't work out. So we use both our knowledge from research and then evidence-based and operational expertise to really look at what, as I mentioned, those competencies. that are needed, and then specifically design multi-method ways to look into those competencies. So we can start to get a picture of what someone might be like behaviorally in such an extreme environment and if they'd be able to effectively cope.
你知道的，不能仅仅依靠自我报告的勾选项，然后继续你的生活，并祈祷他们回答得正确，因为会有大约两万人在韧性这一项上给出五分（满分五分）。然后你把他们塞进一个铁罐头里，结果却行不通。因此，我们既利用从研究中获得的知识，又运用基于证据的实践和运营专业知识，来真正审视我所提到的那些能力。然后专门设计多方法的方式来深入考察这些能力。这样我们就可以开始大致了解某人在这种极端环境下的行为表现会是怎样，以及他们是否能够有效地应对。
Your team recently completed the first round of a simulated Mars mission called Chippea, the crew health and performance exploration analog. Tell us about that. I mean, that sounds like a dry run for actually doing one of these long trips. Oh, yeah. Chappia is a phenomenal project. So Chupia, we put a crew of four in an isolated and confined environment for 378 days. So they didn't go home at night. They're in there. And when they are living in that habitat, we expose them to Mars resource restricted environment. So an example is right now on the ISS, we can send care packages and do things like set.
你们的团队最近完成了模拟火星任务“查皮亚”（Chappa）的第一轮测试，即“机组健康与绩效探索模拟舱”（crew health and performance exploration analog）。跟我们聊聊这个吧。我的意思是，这听起来像是实际执行这些长期任务的一次预演。哦，是的。“查皮亚”是一个非凡的项目。所以“查皮亚”，我们将一个四人机组置于一个孤立且受限的环境中长达 378 天。所以他们晚上不回家。他们就待在里面。当他们生活在该生境中时，我们将他们置于火星资源受限的环境中。举个例子，目前在国际空间站，我们可以发送补给包并做一些事情，比如定期设置
fresh food supply periodically. And that gives them just enough variation in their diet where they still eat and don't, they do lose some weight, but they're able to maintain their health and readiness. When we're talking about Mars, we'll probably have to preposition food before the crew's even selected. So the team here will have to choose what's being prepositioned. And so what we did in Chappia was restrict the environment in those types of ways, restrict water usage, restrict the food that they were given to be Mars realistic. We restricted their communication with friends and family so that it was on that between a 12 and 22 minute communication delay. And so it was really this amazing circumstance where then we're able to collect multidisciplinary data that gives us a look
新鲜食物供应。这为他们的饮食提供了恰到好处的变化，使他们依然能够进食并且不会——虽然他们确实会减轻一些体重，但他们能够维持自己的健康和准备状态。当我们谈论火星时，我们可能必须在机组人员选定之前就预先部署食物。因此，这里的团队必须选择要预先部署什么。所以在“查皮亚”项目中，我们所做的是以这些方式限制环境，限制用水量，限制提供给他们的食物以使其符合火星的实际情况。我们限制了他们与朋友和家人的沟通，使其处于 12 到 22 分钟的通信延迟之间。因此，这确实是一种了不起的环境，在此环境中，我们能够收集多学科的数据，让我们得以观察
on how things like nutrition and behavioral health and performance and exercise and all of these different domains related to human health and performance can interact and what kinds of trades we would have to make to really help someone survive and thrive in those circumstances. So that was, it's a really important study that we're doing that allows us to do those interdisciplinary trades around what do people need to sustain their health in that type of environment. And what were some of the most important lessons that came out of that mission? Well, we are gearing up for mission too. So the way the project was designed, is we actually have a three mission campaign where we at the outset have designed it in certain ways
营养、行为健康、绩效、运动以及与人类健康和绩效相关的所有这些不同领域之间是如何相互作用的，以及为了真正帮助某人在这些环境中生存和茁壮成长，我们必须做出什么样的权衡。所以，这是一项非常重要的研究，它使我们能够围绕人们在这种类型环境中维持健康所需的东西进行跨学科的权衡。那次任务中得出的最重要的一些教训是什么？嗯，我们正在为任务二做准备。所以该项目的初始设计方式是，我们实际上开展了三次任务的活动，我们在开始时就以某些方式对其进行了设计，
to be able to look at our key objectives for the key manipulations that we're interested in for this. And so we do have trends from the first crew, but we're not really talking too much about those because we want to be careful to not chase after trends that were an anomaly of this particular crew. And we'll combine that with data we'll be getting from mission two and mission three. and then we'll be able to, you know, start to see these important trends and what trades will need to make to ensure that they have cognitive function and, you know, are able to meet the physical demands of extra vehicular activities and all the just various things that will be demands on them physically and psychologically. Was anything surprising that came out of this?
以便能够查看我们针对此次感兴趣的关键操控的关键目标。因此，我们确实有来自第一批机组人员的趋势数据，但我们并没有过多谈论这些，因为我们希望谨慎行事，不去追逐那些可能只是这个特定机组人员特例的趋势。我们将把这些数据与从任务二和任务三中获得的数据结合起来，然后我们将能够，你知道的，开始看到这些重要的趋势，以及为了确保他们具备认知功能，并且（你知道的）能够满足舱外活动以及对其在身体和心理上提出各种要求的各种身体需求的物理要求，我们需要做出哪些权衡。其中有什么令人惊讶的事情吗？
You know, I don't know if surprising the right word is the right word, but I think that, you know, from being in the weeds day after day in the project, you know, my lab heavily supports that project. And it really is difficult to be in isolation for 378 days. And sometimes I think when, you know, you see a crew come out smiling and everything looks good. It's like, oh, good. Well, that's, you know, it's just on the next four. But, you know, that is a carefully selected crew to be astronaut-like. So we were able to use a lot of our wisdom from how to select astronauts and apply that to the crew. So these are carefully chosen crew, carefully trained and prepared and carefully supported crew. And even with that, you know, we saw different challenges.
你知道的，我不知道“惊讶”是不是用词恰当，但我认为，你知道的，由于日复一日地深入参与该项目（我的实验室大力支持该项目），在孤立环境中待上 378 天确实非常困难。有时我认为，当，你知道的，你看到机组人员微笑着走出来，一切看起来都很好时，就会觉得，哦，很好。好吧，那是，你知道的，这只是下四个人的事。但是，你知道的，那是经过精心挑选、具备宇航员特质的机组人员。因此，我们能够运用大量关于如何选拔宇航员的智慧，并将其应用到机组人员身上。所以，这些是经过精心挑选的机组人员，经过精心培训和准备，并得到精心支持的机组人员。即便如此，你知道的，我们还是看到了不同的挑战。
And so I think the important takeaway is all of our notions that, yeah, that seems like an extreme and challenging environment. You know, that is definitely true, as well as making difficult trades around how do you support that? crew. So a challenge for space is always payload. So how much can you actually send to space? I mean, if the exercise equipment is not the right equipment and how much payload can you actually spend on the exercise equipment or does more of it need to be on food or water? And it's a constant trade to be able to sustain life in such a complex environment that it's really important for to have multidisciplinary projects like Chappia, where we get that comprehensive data look at human health and performance, including behavioral health and teamwork and team functioning,
因此，我认为重要的结论是，我们所有的看法——是的，那似乎是一个极端且充满挑战的环境——（你知道的）这绝对是真的，同时也要围绕如何支持该机组人员做出艰难的权衡。因此，太空任务面临的一个挑战始终是载荷。也就是你能实际向太空发送多少东西？我的意思是，如果运动器材不是合适的器材，你实际上能在运动器材上花多少载荷，或者是不是需要将更多的载荷分配给食物或水？在如此复杂的环境中维持生命是一个持续的权衡过程，因此拥有像“查皮亚”这样能够获得关于人类健康和绩效（包括行为健康、团队合作和团队功能）的全面数据视图的多学科项目是非常重要的，
so that we can make those important trades and actually do this where we're going to Mars and really sending what the crew needs and making the highest priority on what's the absolute must-haves for the mission. How do you protect an astronaut's mental health in a situation like this? I mean, what happens if you are year out? And you suddenly have, you're freaking out. I mean, this isn't what I expected, you know. I mean, how do you counsel somebody who might be having some kind of anxiety, for example? I mean, I know you try to screen for that beforehand, but who knows what might happen to somebody out there in space. Yeah, absolutely, especially when we look to exploration missions of the future. Right now, behavioral health
这样我们才能做出这些重要的权衡，并真正实现火星之旅，切实发送机组人员真正需要的东西，并将任务绝对必须品置于最高优先级。在这样的情况下，你如何保护宇航员的心理健康？我的意思是，如果你在太空中执行任务已经一年了，会发生什么？你突然遇到了这种情况，你崩溃了。我的意思是，这并不是我所期望的，你知道的。我的意思是，你如何辅导某个可能正在经历某种焦虑的人？我的意思是，我知道你事先会试图对此进行筛查，但谁知道太空中可能会发生什么呢？是的，绝对如此，尤其是当我们展望未来的探索任务时。目前，行为健康
is well managed in the ISS. And one of the things that happens is a private psychological conference where they get to talk with an operational psychologist during the missions. They have one of their key coping strategies that they use is talking to their friends and family. So just like we rely on our families for support on Earth, so do ISS astronauts and the International Space Station astronauts. And then also, as you mentioned, selection. When we move to future missions, that's exactly what my lab really focuses on, is what is the tech development and countermeasure development for these types of things that might happen when, you know, we are in these more extreme conditions that we're expecting. And so one of the things we do in our research is what we call characterize the risks.
在国际空间站得到了很好的管理。发生的情况之一是进行一次私密的心理会议，让他们在任务期间有机会与运营心理学家交谈。他们使用的关键应对策略之一就是与朋友和家人交谈。因此，就像我们在地球上依靠家人寻求支持一样，国际空间站的宇航员也是如此。然后，正如你所提到的，还有选拔。当我们转向未来的任务时，这正是我的实验室真正关注的重点，即针对我们在预期的更极端条件下可能会发生的此类情况，应该进行怎样的技术开发和应对措施开发。因此，我们在研究中所做的事情之一就是我们所谓的“表征风险”。
So even understanding what are the most important things likely to pop up. And so, for example, in all of our analog research or research that's designed to mimic the reality as a future spaceflight, we don't have evidence of like clinical levels of depression. So that wouldn't be a primary thing we would. worry about. Now, would we still have a countermeasure available, of course? But what we might worry about more is team dynamics, that when subgroups start to form, what can happen is when you stop liking someone, it seems like, oh, well, so what? You don't like them. Well, when you live in a small space like
因此，甚至要了解最有可能出现的重要事情是什么。因此，例如，在我们所有的模拟研究中，或者旨在模仿未来太空飞行现实的研究中，我们没有临床水平抑郁症的证据。所以那不会是我们主要担心的事。现在，我们是否仍然会准备好应对措施？当然会。但我们可能会更担心的是团队动力，即当子群开始形成时，可能会发生的情况是，当你开始不喜欢某人时，这似乎是，哦，好吧，那又怎样？你不喜欢他们。好吧，当你生活在那样一个小空间里，
that and you're doing very complicated feats, the problem is, is in our data, when we've observed subgrouping or an isolate, which is one person kind of alienating themselves or even being ostracized by the group and not connecting as well with the rest of the group. That has detrimental effects on their ability to meet mission objectives. And so if you can't meet mission objectives, you know, why are you going? And including, you know, making sure you can have safe backup behaviors to keep that crew alive. And so we work very hard on thinking about how we are developing the team interventions and countermeasures of the future.
并且你在执行非常复杂的壮举时，问题在于，根据我们的数据，当我们观察到子群划分或被孤立——即某人有点自我疏离，甚至被群体边缘化，无法与群体的其余部分进行良好连接时——这对他们实现任务目标的能力有着有害的影响。因此，如果你无法实现任务目标，你知道的，你为什么还要去？包括，你知道的，确保你能采取安全的备份行为来让那个机组人员保持活命。因此，我们非常努力地思考如何开发未来的团队干预措施和应对措施。
We use standard things too, like a continuous learning and a team learning to debrief or teach themselves, you know, like, what do we do well? What didn't we do well? What do we need to do in the future? That's still best practices, even if you're in a tin can. But the reality is we need more. And so we're looking at ways for if someone has a mental health challenge or behavioral health challenge, if there is team dysfunction. How do we detect that? And then how do we empower the crew to be able to address that themselves because they're going to be autonomous on this long mission delay? And then we would like that as much as possible to be self-initiated. However, there's strategies for when another person has to intervene to. And then at what point does mission control or something else, you know, begin to intervene? And so those are the exact types of research challenges that we're currently working on in the lab. So I can only kind of answer your question right now. But that is definitely what we're working on.
我们也使用常规的方法，比如持续学习和团队学习来进行复盘或自我指导，你知道的，比如：我们哪些方面做得好？哪些方面没做好？我们未来需要做什么？即使你被关在铁罐头里，这仍然是最佳实践。但现实是我们需要更多。因此，我们正在寻找方法：如果某人遇到心理健康挑战或行为健康挑战，或者如果出现团队功能失调。我们该如何检测到这一点？然后，我们如何赋能机组人员，让他们能够自己解决这些问题，因为在这个漫长的任务延迟中，他们将是自主的？然后，我们希望在最大程度上由他们自主发起。然而，当其他人不得不进行干预时，也有相应的策略。然后，任务控制中心或其他机构在什么时间点开始介入？这些正是我们目前在实验室中致力于解决的具体研究挑战。所以现在我只能回答你的一部分问题。但那绝对是我们正在努力的方向。
And, you know, have me back on the show three years from now. I'll tell you about all the things that we've developed. How do you balance the need for astronauts to be leaders, but team players? That's a wonderful question, Kim, because astronauts, by the time they've gotten to where they are, are high achievers, right? So they usually don't suffer in their ability to lead. They've risen through the ranks, whether military or non-military and been successful in their jobs and are high-achieving people in general. And so the leadership capabilities are often there. But what's really important, particularly in spaceflight, but really in other teams,
而且，你知道的，三年后再邀请我上节目。我会告诉你我们开发的所有成果。你如何平衡宇航员既要成为领导者、又要成为团队合作者的需求？这是一个绝妙的问题，金，因为宇航员能走到今天这一步，都是高成就者，对吧？所以他们通常在领导能力方面不会有所欠缺。无论是在军队还是非军队系统中，他们都通过层层晋升，在工作中取得了成功，总体上是高成就的人。因此，领导才能往往是具备的。但真正重要的是，尤其是在太空飞行中，但在其他团队中也同样如此，
is that someone understands and knows when to lead, but also when to follow. And so it's really about can people also follow at the right time? And following doesn't mean being passive. Good followership is still using your critical thinking skills and pushing information up to the decision maker and pulling information so you can provide the right inputs. It's very active. You know, we have this like stereotype of like, oh, followers, just like a sheep following someone around. But when we talk about leadership followership in the astronaut context, we still want proactive critical thinking, but we also want people who can acknowledge maybe on this particular
那就是一个人要理解并知道何时去领导，但也要知道何时去追随。因此，这真正关乎人们是否也能在合适的时间选择追随？而追随并不意味着被动。优秀的追随力仍然需要运用你的批判性思维技能，将信息向上反馈给决策者，并拉取信息以便你能提供正确的输入。这是非常主动的。你知道的，我们有一种这样的刻板印象，哦，追随者就像一只羊一样跟着别人走。但当我们讨论宇航员语境中的领导与追随关系时，我们仍然希望有积极主动的批判性思维，但我们也希望人们能够承认，或许在这个特定的
problem, someone else is the primary expert. And so I'm going to allow them to take the lead. But when I have expertise that's relevant, I need to provide that or even be comfortable taking the lead. So, yes, there will probably be a commander and a crew that's following. But that leadership followership and really being able to negotiate that role between and that role change between the two is really important for spaceflight. And I would actually argue a lot of teams and in, you know, that shared leadership components. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199.
问题上，其他人才是主要的专家。因此，我要让他们占据主导地位。但当我拥有相关的专业知识时，我需要提供这些专业知识，甚至乐于承担领导责任。所以，是的，可能会有一位指挥官和一个追随的机组人员。但这种领导与追随的关系，以及真正能够在这两者之间协商角色和角色转换，对于太空飞行而言非常重要。而且我实际上会说，对于许多团队以及在那种共享领导力的组成部分中，这也同样重要。家得宝 (The Home Depot) 的阵亡将士纪念日特惠让你的夏天现在开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四 burner 燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。
And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. So you mentioned people back home being sort of a mitigating factor when astronauts start to feel whatever pressures, lonely, anxious, all of those things. How much time do you spend, assuming that you do, screening their families to make sure that the relationships that they have back home are solid and healthy?
还可以用汉普顿湾西格罗夫 (Hampton Bay West Grove) 七件套户外餐桌椅套装尽情招待一整个夏天，特价仅需 49 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，不适用于部分情况。详情请参见 Home Depot.com 上的价格匹配。所以你提到家乡的人们是一种缓解因素，当宇航员开始感受到任何压力、孤独、焦虑所有这些事情时。假设你确实这么做了，你花了多少时间来筛查他们的家人，以确保他们在老家的关系是稳固且健康的？
So that currently is not part of what we do, but as you're pointing out, making sure the support unit is, is strong, is going to be critically important for these longer missions where someone is gone for a long period of time. And not only making sure that the family is on board and supported and that everybody has the shared expectation of what's happening, but some of our interventions we're working on is how do you keep the family involved in the story as it evolves? So especially when you have that communication delay. So we have research projects that are, for example, looking at VR capabilities and how you can have a shared experience with your family there. We have other work that we're starting to look at related to, you know, how can we encourage shared experiences
所以这目前不是我们工作的一部分，但正如你所指出的，确保支持单元是强大的，对于某人要离开很长时间的这些更长期任务来说，将是至关重要的。不仅要确保家人加入并获得支持，以及每个人对正在发生的事情有共同的期望，而且我们正在进行的其中一些干预措施之一是，如何在故事发展的过程中让家人参与进来？尤其是当你面临通信延迟时。因此，我们有研究项目，例如，正在研究虚拟现实 (VR) 功能，以及你如何能与那里的家人共享体验。我们还有其他正在开始研究的工作，关于（你知道的）我们如何才能鼓励共享体验，
and the type of communication that deepens relationships over time when you are separated at that long distance. And so we look at it at short communication delays like we're expecting for Artemis, but we also are starting to evolve some of our research for a Mars focus and how we'll support that. One thing we do right now on the International Space Station, the behavioral health and performance operational group here, has specialists who actually partner with the family and help them with this journey. And that can really be helpful not only to the family unit, but back for the astronaut because they view the family as an important coping mechanism. But if they're too worried about their family and what's happening on Earth, it can also detract from their ability to do the hard
以及那种在长途分隔时能够随着时间加深关系的沟通类型。因此，我们既着眼于像我们对阿尔忒密斯任务所预期的那样短的通信延迟，同时也开始发展一些针对火星任务的研究以及我们将如何对此提供支持。目前我们在国际空间站做的一件事是，这里的行为健康与绩效运营小组拥有专门的专家，他们实际上与家属建立伙伴关系，并在这次旅程中帮助他们。这不仅对家庭单元非常有帮助，对宇航员本人也大有裨益，因为他们将家庭视为一种重要的应对机制。但是，如果他们过分担心家人以及地球上发生的事情，这也可能会削弱他们执行艰巨且
and difficult work that they're doing on the space station. Because even though the space station is larger, like I mentioned, and isn't quite as extreme as some of our, what we're planning for Mars. They are busy and work very hard in the International Space Station because there are so many science projects that they're supposed to execute and maintenance that needs to be done for the International Space Station. And so it might be still a little bit roomier than we're expecting for Mars, but it's still challenging. They still have to keep their eye in the ball. They're still going out and risking their lives on spacewalks. And so, if they're worried about how their child's doing in school or, you know, whether or not their
困难工作的能力，而这些工作正是他们在空间站上所做的。因为尽管空间站正如我所提到的那样更大一些，而且不像我们为火星计划的那些环境那么极端。他们在国际空间站上非常忙碌，工作非常努力，因为有太多的科学项目需要他们执行，还有国际空间站需要完成的维护工作。因此，它可能仍然比我们对火星的预期要宽敞一些，但它依然充满挑战。他们仍然必须全神贯注。他们仍然要外出并在太空行走中冒着生命危险。因此，如果他们担心孩子在学校表现如何，或者（你知道的）他们的
spouse or partner is coping well, that can really add to their stress, which is already significant. And so we really support the families with specialists who form a relationship with the family before they even leave and then partner with that family to help the mission to be a success for the astronaut and their supportive unit at home. how do you plan enough redundancy to make the mission successful? So you've only got four people and say one person is down for a month with illness or, God forbid, somebody dies on the mission. How do you cover the work that they were doing? One of the things is sending redundancies in critical skills. So what would be mission ending, for example? And one of it would be if there was no
配偶或伴侣是否应付得过来，这确实会增加本已相当重大的压力。因此，我们确实通过专家来支持家属，这些专家在他们离开之前就与家属建立了关系，然后与该家属合作，帮助任务对宇航员及其在家的支持单元来说取得成功。你如何规划足够的冗余来确保任务成功？因此，你只有四个人，假设其中一人因病倒下一个月，或者上帝保佑，有人在任务中牺牲了。你如何弥补他们正在做的工作？其中一件事就是在关键技能上发送冗余。例如，什么样的情况会终结任务？其中之一就是如果没有
physician or medical support. And so when we think about crude composition for something like a mission to Mars, it'll be important to not only have a physician or medical expert of some sorts, but also someone who, if that's not their primary expertise, are well trained in those areas so they could step in, for example, if it's the physician that's sick. We're also developing technologies at NASA and with other commercial and university and different entities to do things like be able to provide just in time support training for things, like giving an ultrasound, like doing a minor surgery, you might end up having to do it. And so, you know, how can we, if needed, train someone to do those things on a significant communication delay? And so there's anything,
医生或医疗支持。因此，当我们考虑诸如火星任务之类的机组构成时，不仅要有一位某种形式的医生或医疗专家，而且还要有这样一个人：即使那不是他们的主要专业，他们也在这些领域接受过良好培训，以便他们能够介入，例如，如果生病的是医生的话。我们还在 NASA 以及与其他商业、大学和不同实体合作开发技术，以实现诸如能够为诸如进行超声波检查、进行小型手术之类的事情提供即时支持培训，你最终可能不得不这样做。因此，你知道的，如果需要的话，我们如何培训某人在显着的通信延迟下做这些事情？因此，有任何，
there's a couple different projects, but anything from like AI supports for medical interventions to really cool projects that do things like mimic a lack of gravity and employees. for when you're performing a surgery. Because if you think about it, I mean, it would be hard enough to perform a surgery if you didn't know how to do one. But now you're in microgravity. So just to add in some more fun for that. So those are the complicated things that, yes, we need to keep the crew alive.
有几个不同的项目，但从用于医疗干预的人工智能支持，到做诸如在员工中模拟失重状态之类真正酷的项目的任何东西。用于你进行手术的时候。因为如果你仔细想想，我的意思是，如果你不知道怎么做，进行一台手术已经够难的了。但现在你处于微重力环境中。所以这只是为它增添更多乐趣。因此，这些都是复杂的事情，是的，我们需要让机组人员保持活命。
We need critical redundancies and medical expertise. And then, you know, we will evolve as our mission objectives evolve to what the other technical expertise are that need to be redundant. Now, you recently co-authored a paper that looked at how living in space affected astronauts' cognition on the International Space Station. What did you find and would you expect to find similar results for a Mars mission crew? This is a really significant study for us. It was led by Dr. Sheena Dev in my lab and in our behavioral health and performance lab. And what we did is we looked at six-month missions to the International Space Station.
我们需要医疗专业知识方面的关键冗余。然后，你知道的，随着我们的任务目标不断演变，我们将不断发展，以确定哪些是需要具备冗余的其他技术专业知识。现在，你最近是某篇论文的共同第一作者，该论文探讨了在太空生活如何影响宇航员在国际空间站上的认知。你们发现了什么？你预计火星任务机组人员也会有类似的结果吗？这对我们来说是一项非常重大的研究。它由我实验室的希娜·德夫 (Sheena Dev) 博士和我们的行为健康与绩效实验室共同领导。我们所做的是观察了为期六个月的国际空间站任务，
and tracked cognitive change over time using a specially developed cognitive performance measure that we give called cognition. It looks at 10 different dimensions of cognitive performance. And there's actually really good news from that study, which is in low Earth orbit. So again, you're not exposed to that much radiation and some of the challenges we're expecting for future. What we saw was some slowing in some of the responses to processing speed tasks, visual work. working memory tasks and sustained attention early on in the mission and some changes to risk-taking propensity. But what's interesting is the changes like processing speed, visual working memory, sustained attention. These are the types of changes that you might expect in stressful environments
并使用一种我们称之为“认知”（cognition）的、专门开发的认知绩效测量方法，随着时间的推移追踪认知变化。它着眼于认知绩效的 10 个不同维度。该研究实际上有一个非常好的消息，那就是在近地轨道中。所以再次说明，你没有暴露于那么多的辐射中，也没有暴露于我们对未来所预期的一些挑战中。我们看到的是，在任务早期，处理速度任务、视觉工作记忆任务和持续注意力任务的某些反应出现了一些减慢，并且风险承担倾向发生了一些变化。但有趣的是，诸如处理速度、视觉工作记忆、持续注意力等变化。这些正是你可能在地球上的压力环境中，
on Earth or when someone's sleep deprived on Earth. And so the good news is we actually concluded that there's no evidence for a systematic decline in cognitive performance for astronauts on these six-month missions to the ISS. I'm going to answer your question in a second, but that is really important because one of the things we're focusing on is commercializing space, and we want space tourists and someday for everybody to have the opportunity to go to space or at least a lot more people than go now. And so knowing that, hey, even astronauts who stay up in six-month missions to the ISS, you don't have to worry that you're going to have some cognitive decline because of that. And so that shouldn't be a concern.
或者当某人在地球上睡眠不足时所预期的那种变化。因此好消息是，我们实际上得出了结论：没有证据表明前往国际空间站执行这些六个月任务的宇航员的认知绩效会出现系统性下降。我一会儿再回答你的问题，但这非常重要，因为我们关注的焦点之一是商业化太空，我们希望太空游客以及有一天每个人都有机会去太空，或者至少比现在去的人多得多。因此，知道——嘿，甚至是在国际空间站执行六个月任务的宇航员，你也不必担心由于这个原因你会遇到任何认知下降。因此这不应该是一个担忧。
And so that's a great, like, starting place. But what we're going to also use this research for is baseline research. So our next goals are to go to the moon. That's going to be exposure to a lot more of the hazards of space. And so we'll be able to use for people who are into statistics like Bayesian approaches, where we can say, okay, here's what we know from the International Space Station, low Earth orbit. And then as we get astronaut crews who are going around,
所以这是一个很好的起点。但我们也将利用这项研究作为基准研究。因此我们的下一个目标是登月。那将接触到更多太空危害。因此，对于那些喜欢统计学的人来说，我们可以使用诸如贝叶斯方法（Bayesian approaches）之类的方法，我们可以说，好吧，这就是我们从国际空间站、近地轨道了解到的情况。然后，随着我们有了绕行月球的宇航员机组，
on the moon, we can update that to really characterize what's happening in cognition as we go beyond low Earth orbit to the moon and then someday beyond. But we can't answer your question yet. We do conduct analog research and we will be collecting data on the Artemis missions that will look at that. And those are always low sample. And so having this baseline for at least our best guess of where to start and then looking at deviations from that is going to be really powerful for us. Are the skills and characteristics for NASA astronaut different from those astronauts who are working on commercial flights? Yeah. So this goes back to when I said, you know, it depends on the type of mission. So you might have a Mars mission where you're two and a half years in isolation. Some of the private sector missions right now might be two to four days. Some even, you know, just go up and kind of come down.
在月球上，我们可以更新这些数据，以真正表征当我们超越近地轨道前往月球并在某一天走得更远时，认知正在发生什么。但我们还无法回答你的问题。我们确实开展了模拟研究，并且我们将在阿尔忒密斯任务上收集研究认知的数据。这些样本总是很小。因此，拥有这个基准（至少是我们对起点的最佳猜测），然后观察与该基准的偏差，对我们来说将是非常有力的。NASA 宇航员的技能和特征与那些在商业航班上工作的宇航员不同吗？是的。所以这回到了我之前所说的，你知道的，这取决于任务的类型。因此，你可能会执行一次为期两年半处于孤立状态的火星任务。目前一些私营部门的任务可能是两到 four 天。有些甚至（你知道的）只是上去然后下来。
So those are going to require different profiles. It also will depend on what you are doing on the mission. So if you're expected to do research versus if you are just a, you know, a space tourist and can decide what you want to do with your time. And so for each mission, you know, that needs to be considered. And then making sure people have the kind of minimum critical capabilities and competencies where they can succeed in a mission like that. So it's safe for everybody. Does the research that you're doing at NASA have any more practical applications on Earth?
因此，这些将需要不同的个人资料。这也将取决于你在任务中做什么。因此，如果你被期望做研究，与如果你只是一个（你知道的）太空游客并可以决定如何利用你的时间相比。因此，对于每次任务，你知道的，这都需要加以考虑。然后确保人们具备最低限度的关键能力和胜任力，以便他们能够在这样的任务中取得成功。这样对每个人来说都是安全的。你在 NASA 正在做的研究在地球上还有其他更实际的应用吗？
One of the things that I love about my job is what we do is difficult with our analog research, with our small sample research. So a lot of times we're innovating methodologies alongside with better understanding human functioning and the psychology of people in extreme environments. So in a couple ways. One is we've had, we've innovated around different machine learning and computational models. The end of them themselves were the first of their kind and have made advances in those areas, which can be applied back to how we understand teamwork on Earth, among other things. But also some of the research that NASA funds, for example, looking at how teams might debrief and be more effective. Those are used not only in the
我热爱我的工作的原因之一，在于我们的类比研究和小样本研究充满挑战。因此，很多时候我们在创新方法论的同时，也能更好地理解极端环境中人类的机能和人类心理。具体体现在几个方面。首先，我们在不同的机器学习和计算模型方面进行了创新。这些模型本身就是同类中的首创，并在这些领域取得了进展，除其他外，这些进展还可以应用于我们如何理解地球上的团队合作。此外，NASA资助的一些研究，例如探讨团队如何进行复盘以及如何变得更高效，这些不仅被用于
research, but in practice, in areas like astronauts, but for people who work on oil rigs, or in a group living paper that we just published, that has application for anyone who lives and works together, whether it's deployed military units, whether it's people on an oil rig, whether it's even, you know, going to summer camp and you want to think about, you know, when you're living together, you know, what are the fundamental skills needed for group living? And so everything we do, You know, it has to be pioneering to conquer the challenges in spaceflight, but there's very little that we do that wouldn't have a lessons learned that can promote team effectiveness back on Earth, how we compose teams, how we support teams on Earth, how we monitor teams, as well as innovations and things like understanding cognitive performance. I think that it's really amazing. Like if you think about work today, 50 to 80 percent of an individual's day is spent collaborating. in some way. And so some of these novel things we're pushing to make teamwork in space better have direct implications for making our jobs better and helping us figure out how we can support
研究中，也应用到了实践中，涉及宇航员等领域，还包括在石油钻井平台上工作的人员，或者在我们刚刚发表的一篇关于群居的论文中，它适用于任何生活和工作在一起的人，无论是部署的军事单位，还是石油钻井平台上的人，甚至是你懂的，去参加夏令营时你想去思考的，当大家生活在一起时，群居所需的基石技能是什么？因此我们所做的每一件事，你知道的，都必须具有开创性以克服太空飞行的挑战，但我们所做的很少有不能带来经验教训的，这些教训能够反哺地球，提升团队效能，包括我们如何在地球上构建团队、支持团队、监测团队，以及在理解认知表现等方面的创新。我认为这真的很神奇。如果你想想今天的工作，个人一天中50%到80%的时间都用于某种形式的协作。因此，我们正在推动的一些新方法，旨在让太空中的团队合作变得更好，这对于改善我们的工作以及帮助我们弄清楚如何支持
better teamwork, whether virtually or in person, as most people's jobs are now. How did you wind up at NASA? You moved from academia to the space agency. How did that come about? Yeah, well, I loved being a professor. I came out of grad school and was really passionate about teaching and research and took my first position and really enjoyed my time there with my colleagues. And just like a good academic position would be with, you know, helping me to become a researcher in the areas that I wanted to explore, having that academic freedom component. But one of the things I researched extensively was team composition or how combinations of team members work together. And I had published quite a bit on that. I have a
更好的团队合作（无论是线上的还是线下的，就像现在大多数人的工作方式一样）有着直接的启示。你是怎么来到NASA的？你从学术界转到了太空机构，这是怎么发生的？是的，我很喜欢当教授。我研究生毕业后对教学和研究充满热情，找到了第一份工作，并非常享受在那里与同事们度过的时光。这就和一份好的学术职位一样，你知道的，它帮助我成为一名研究人员，让我能够在我想探索的领域进行研究，并具备学术自由的要素。但我广泛研究的课题之一是团队构成，或者说团队成员的各种组合如何协同工作。我在这方面发表了不少文章。我有一篇
meta-analysis. I have two meta-analyses on that. I have other papers on that as well in research. And then NASA actually reached out when they first started thinking about Mars stuff and said, we're kind of consulting the leading researchers in this area. And we want your input on, you know, how do you compose a crew that'll go to Mars someday? And that was an interesting question, right? It's like, okay, that's not what I thought would be in my inbox today. Like, apparently NASA's going to Mars and they'd like to know what combination of people were best. But I did two smaller studies with NASA and then eventually had some larger grants continuing as a professor that were funded by NASA. And then just over time, it just really became my favorite part of my day.
元分析。我在这方面有两篇元分析。我在研究中还有其他关于这方面的论文。然后，当NASA刚开始考虑火星相关的事情时，他们主动联系了我，说：我们正在咨询这个领域的顶尖研究人员，我们希望你能就如何组建一支有一天能够去火星的机组人员提供意见。这是一个有趣的问题，对吧？当时的想法是，好吧，这可不是我今天以为会出现在收件箱里的内容。听起来NASA要去火星了，他们想知道哪种人员组合最好。后来我和NASA做了两个规模较小的研究，再后来作为教授继续开展了一些由NASA资助的规模更大的资助项目。随着时间推移，这真的成了我一天中最喜欢的部分。
I think personally that becoming an interplanetary species is one of the most important things we can do for humankind. And so I thought, well, I do love my position of my colleagues and the students, but I'm really passionate. about this and do I start this at 5 o'clock after I'm done teaching and, you know, doing service stuff all day or try to start it at 8 a.m. It's exciting because of the mission of becoming, you know, successfully landing humans on Mars someday. Also exciting because it is so intellectually difficult. And I love that. That gets me up in the morning of saying, how do we even research making this happen, let alone getting there. It's like, how do you even figure out what you need to get there? And so maybe eight or ten years ago, I published a piece on that. I love this idea, though,
我个人认为，成为一个星际物种是对人类最重要的事之一。所以我当时想，虽然我很爱我的职位、我的同事和学生们，但我对此充满热情。我是要在每天上完课、做完各种行政服务工作之后的晚上5点开始搞这个，还是尝试在早上8点就开始？这令人兴奋，因为我们的使命是在某天成功将人类送上火星。它也令人兴奋，因为它在智力上极具挑战性。我喜欢这一点。这让我早晨起床时就会想，我们甚至该如何进行研究来让这件事发生，更不用说真正抵达那里了。这就像是你甚至该如何弄清楚到达那里所需要的东西？所以大概八十年前，我发表了一篇关于这方面的文章。不过我很喜欢这个想法，
of sending equipment or supplies out ahead, you know, like, how am I going to find that 7-Eleven in space? Where is that thing that, you know, we really need? I mean, how, that's going to be pretty challenging. As you mentioned, I'm a psychologist, but we partner closely. I was just in an hour and a half meeting with our food scientist right before I jumped on your podcast. And so everything we do here is multidisciplinary. You know, we want to know how food we send changes performance, changes cognition, does it, you know, do we have wiggle room on the food? What's our minimum we can send? I mean, it's complicated, right? Every gram is important in a payload. And so everything has to be carefully thought through of, you know, I might have the most fantastic VR behavioral health intervention,
那就是把设备或物资提前发送出去，你知道的，比如，我怎么在太空中找到那家7-Eleven便利店？我们真正需要的东西到底在哪里？我的意思是，这将会非常具有挑战性。正如你所提到的，我是一名心理学家，但我们合作非常紧密。就在我加入你的播客之前，我刚和我们的食品科学家开了一个半小时的会。所以我们这里做的每件事都是多学科交叉的。你知道的，我们想了解我们发送的食物如何改变表现、改变认知，它会不会，你知道的，我们在食物上有没有回旋的余地？我们能发送的最低限度是多少？我的意思是，这很复杂，对吧？有效载荷中的每一克都很重要。所以每件事都必须经过深思熟虑，你知道的，我可能拥有最棒的VR行为健康干预手段，
but if I don't even have the payload to send the VR device, it doesn't do me any good. And so understanding is that more important than a little more food? That's a hard question, right? And that's the questions we grapple with because we know that we need people who are psychologically ready to perform as individuals, to perform as teams, to be able to maintain their wellness, to do things like two hours of exercise a day, just to keep their bones from losing too much density and to keep their muscles from atrophying in a lower no-gravity environment. And so, like, we know they have to do all these things, but making those trades is what's fundamentally, I think, the most challenging things, because we don't have the ability to send whatever we want, and we don't have the ability to make
但如果我连发送VR设备的有效载荷都没有，那它就对我一点帮助也没有。因此，弄清楚这个是否比多带一点食物更重要？这是一个很难的问题，对吧？这也是我们极力应对的问题，因为我们知道我们需要在心理上做好准备的人，能够作为个人去表现，作为团队去表现，能够维持他们的健康，去做诸如每天锻炼两小时之类的事情，仅仅是为了防止他们的骨骼失去太多密度，并在低重力或零重力环境中防止肌肉萎缩。所以，你知道的，他们必须做所有这些事情，但进行这些权衡我认为是最具挑战性的事情，因为我们没有能力随心所欲地发送我们想要的东西，我们也没有能力制造
whatever we want. So we have to just figure out what's going to be there to make it work, like you're pointing out. Last question. What's next for your research lab and what are the big priorities? How do you decide what you need to do next? Yeah, we have maybe, it depends how you count them, but probably over 25 projects. We're a very busy lab now. We have different priorities. We always just follow along with mission agency priorities. So, you know, we're consistent with that. But then what we do is, depending on what the agency is prioritizing, what are the unsolved challenges related to making that happen. So, for example, when we're talking about returning to the moon and creating a sustained presence on the moon, one of the things that's extremely difficult about that is the number
我们想要的任何东西。所以我们只能弄清楚有什么东西能让它发挥作用，就像你所指出的那样。最后一个问题。你的研究实验室下一步的计划是什么？重中之重是什么？你如何决定接下来需要做什么？是的，我们大概有——这取决于你如何计算它们——可能超过25个项目。我们现在是一个非常忙碌的实验室。我们有不同的优先级。我们总是紧跟任务机构的优先级。所以，你知道的，我们与此保持一致。但接下来我们做的是，根据机构的优先事项，弄清楚与实现这一目标相关的未解挑战是什么。例如，当我们谈论重返月球并在月球上建立可持续的存在时，其中一件极其困难的事情就是数量
of extra vehicular activities that will have to be done. It is an unprecedented amount compared to what we've done historically. And so we are currently starting projects that ask the fundamental a question of how much can we push people physically and psychologically with repeated extra vehicular activities. Can you do six-hour EVAs every other day? I'm sorry, an extra vehicular activity, a spacewalk, right? They're challenging. They're physically demanding. They're psychologically demanding. They're cognitively tasking. And right now you have a ramp up period where the person prepares for it. Then they, you know, go on the EVA. Then they can come back and have some downtime. They rarely would be in a circumstance where they'd have to do it
必须进行的舱外活动。与我们历史上的做法相比，这是一个前所未有的数量。因此，我们目前正在启动项目，探讨一个根本问题：通过重复的舱外活动，我们在身体和心理上到底能把人类推向多远？你可以每隔一天进行六小时的EVA吗？抱歉，舱外活动就是太空行走，对吧？它们充满挑战。它们对体力要求很高。它们对心理要求很高。它们在认知上要求很高。目前，你会有一个准备阶段，在这个阶段中，个人会为之做准备。然后他们，你知道的，去进行EVA。然后他们回来并有一些休息时间。他们很少会处于这样一种情况下：他们必须这样做
six hours and then the next, you know, two days later, six hours again. So a lot of our high priority research right now is focused on optimizing cognitive and physical performance on those extra vehicular activities so we can actually create a sustained presence on the moon. Those are some of our big current starting projects right now. And then that will be used to inform schedulers and mission planners so they can say, okay, if there's too much cognitive fatigue after a six-hour EBA, I can't put these types of tasks towards the end of it because there's too many errors. There's too many safety issues. And so keeping the crew safe, meeting as many objectives as we can, that would be an example. You know, as our agency is also focused on
六个小时，然后紧接着，你知道的，两天后又是六个小时。因此，我们目前许多高优先级的研究都集中在优化这些舱外活动中的认知和体能表现上，这样我们才能真正在月球上建立可持续的存在。这些是我们目前正在启动的一些重大项目。然后，这些项目将被用来为日程安排人员和任务规划人员提供参考，让他们能够说，好吧，如果在六小时的EVA之后有太多的认知疲劳，我就不能把这类任务安排在接近尾声的时候，因为会有太多的错误。会有太多的安全问题。因此，保障机组人员的安全，尽可能多地实现我们的目标，这就是一个例子。你知道的，随着我们机构的重点也在于
going to Mars someday. And so we're also really starting to work on, we've done some work now characterizing the risks. And so we're now really starting to develop countermeasures. And so we, we are starting in our new work, really specifically the tech development, the countermeasure development to mitigate the risks we see like declines in social support over time is one of the things we just published actually about two weeks ago. So yeah. Well, I want to thank you for joining me. This is amazing work that you're doing and thank you for doing it. I look forward to seeing the day when we actually go back to the moon and make our way to Mars. Wouldn't be wonderful? Well, thank you for having me, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof
有朝一日前往火星。因此，我们也真正开始着手，我们现在已经做了一些工作来描述这些风险。所以我们现在真的开始开发应对措施。因此，我们在新工作中真正具体开始的是技术开发、应对措施开发，以减轻我们看到的风险，比如随着时间推移社会支持下降，这是我们大约两周前刚刚发表的内容之一。所以，是的。嗯，我想感谢你参与我的节目。这是你正在做的了不起的工作，谢谢你为之付出。我期待着看到我们真正重返月球并走向火星的那一天。那不是很棒吗？好吧，谢谢你邀请我，吉姆。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof
psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's att.a.ap.a. APA.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
psychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评价。对于那些想要更多了解心理学和 APA 工作的人，你可以作为支持者加入我们。你不需要成为一名心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology），以及购买书籍和其他出版物的折扣。因此，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者你只是想更多地了解这门科学，你可以通过访问 at.a.a.org 斜杠 speaking 来成为支持者。也就是 att.a.ap.a. APA.org 斜杠 speaking。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，你可以给我们发邮件至 speaking of psychology
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup.
在 APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的吉姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松一下，本周让拉尔夫送货（Ralph's Delivery）来帮你搞定食品杂货采购。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后检查你的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们会把它们全部打包好，并在短短30分钟内送达，让你确信这就是你所订购的东西。新鲜杂货，尽在你的掌控，尽在拉尔夫配送与自提（Ralph's Delivery and Pickup）。
And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，你的第一笔配送或自提订单还可以立减20美元。拉尔夫超市，为每个人保持新鲜。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。